five accomplished in ice cubes in this
vid okay now this is so small the number
here five then you could actually
literally write this holster here
however if not has changes such that
like I don't know I know
around 16 times really the Sun will set
in your own different okay so what you
want to do is you want to take advantage
of the fact that you can state the
general term of this extension right and
then just go straight to the one which
has a power of 3 for the X so if you
thought I'm going to write I'm going to
say 4 plus X to the 5 general term must
be the general term term number n is
going to be all right now
every term in the binomial expansions
can have three pieces right it's going
to have the binomial coefficient it's
going to have some number of these guys
and then it's going to some number of
these guys so I just need to work out
all of the bits that go is there the
power is 5 so we roll Pascal's triangle
now on this is the fifth root right
remembering that we start with a zero or
throw one two three four five so it's
going to be five see something namely
whichever term you're on to publishers
that are actually but doesn't know okay
then I'm going to say well how many
fours will I have coming forward if all
of the in turn I will probably have I
can say it in either way I can have one
of these will be 5 minus N and what will
be n I'm interested in these X terms
right so I'm going to make this one n
and this one's fun - M okay and you can
like if I started to expand with me you
would see the first term is going to be
5 C 0 times which there cannot first so
X now the force doesn't matter which one
you do doesn't matter because it
symmetrical right but I'm just trying to
choose the most convenient one that goes
to 0 thing up like because when you like
finally the club
sometimes I don't get how you can just
put how eager them cool okay so I'll
show you I've actually like I said I can
write this whole thing up so I'm going
to go 5 1 4 4 X to the 1 do you see
what's happening to the talent which is
kind of always a define which is like
these pallets always after 5 5 C 2 4
cubed x squared I only need one more I
think to make my point okay there we go
plus dot dot dot
yeah there's only a 450 turns left now
this I can state my general term let me
show you how to solve it this way I
didn't show you how to do a backwards
not be the kind of thing I want the X
cubed turn right
so therefore it's going to have n equal
3 to get the X cubes right so therefore
2 3 is going to be 5 C 3 4 to the power
of 2 X cubed this isn't one that I wrote
a single time okay so I can work out of
5 C 3 is which was that 10 I think it's
going to kidnap printers then there are
times six days XQ to the air type
respect in 160 okay is it really the 10
so it is a sort of finish from the
conquer pass it's a map yeah it's from
the binomial coefficient and in the 16
is from this guy here okay now how do I
done this in Reverse and then actually T
of n is going to be 5 the N 4 to the N X
- 5 - and you can see I can look at it
from the opposite perspective I then ask
yourself what value of n will give me
the X cubed term and it's going to be -
is it it can elevate is 5 minus 2
there's my X cubed so I'll try out too -
okay that's going to be 5 feet - 4 to
the 2x 3 kids right but wait a second
right because 5 feet 3 and 5 see to
adverb same number
getting the same time right it's just
that you've gone from the other end
you've just counted up to the second ten
percent certain but it's exactly so in
that work because of that evening they
could just the Powerman even numbers
well it will always work because every
row excuse triangle is symmetrical will
always work so there's not that's why
when you saw I was writing each other
doesn't really matter which one I think
because there's no way to go you still
get the same solution okay you're either
just counting from the left or your
country from the right but you'll end up
on the same time which other way because
there's only one xq term in there is
that right there okay can you own do not
no question women were like form was 5 1
1 X Y Swisher okay I'm sorry
yeah okay alright so when you go to
trouble day I can no charter it's a
fairly easy extension out of this one so
I want to do it I just need a 100 more
times like 32 of those by means of your
multiplier yeah yeah like one o'clock X
stuck that not like one club okay ^ like
69 like I can do one of those if you
want i'll enter your would first okay so
i'm just going to change this question
slightly let's make it a full on X plus
X square
let me just think of it not gonna work
because they're not what depend on the
extension that you have you don't
necessarily get every single power of X
so the first one he's going to be four
letters five four okay I'm just through
this off in my head so this boys up on
method will work it out okay so here's a
big here's an expansion I'm looking for
the exit of four term that will come out
of this one everything comes down to
wash okay so what I'm going to do is
just like before gonna write the general
Sun so the general term the enter is
going to be there's going to be a
binomial coefficients part of it
right then there's gonna be so these and
it's going to be Sundays
okay now I can do this somewhere to
write life but I'm going to write for
all X that one M and X square will make
that 5 minus X remember I can swap these
it works just fine but you see in a
minute why I've chosen to do it this way
why it might be T bits super fun okay
and this actually does require a little
bit of legwork here when you look at
this you like which one the X cubed term
well just move that three that's the
only thing that can should be sitting
X's in its you just make that three a
problem but here you've got weird stuff
happening to you with the X's then get
it interact with each other other thing
so I'm gonna leave that 5cn at the front
I'm going to write this guy I'm going to
expand some stuff out right so do you
agree that that is four X to the
negative one yeah that's that's 4x
I'm writing it in index notation because
I'm going to need these indices and how
to interact with each other okay
all right so I plan to the end now this
I'm going to break apart again it's a
four to the N and also an X to the minus
n do you see what I did
that's just index laws okay do you say
the over here is going to be X to the
ten minus two M what do you think
sattell right so I prepared of this
understanding this five to the air and
the 4 to 5 cm brother and a four to the
end they just hang up front right there
are no X's in there so I won't worry
about that there but these guys I mean
II do need a column what we're going to
become the new Kia Motors
I'm just going to combine the abilities
when you multiplied numbers with the
same bases you add their indices do
10 minus 3m is an honor okay so now he
is I've done this is the end is no more
simplification I can do I want the X to
the four term right so in other words I
want this thing to become X power 4
well if that's going to become x to
power four X to the 10 minus three is
going to become X to the 4 and clearly
10 minus 3n equals four minus 3 M equals
we're in six early Institute said okay
now by the way to bed that dolls
writings crushing down other what do I
do and I need to make up a table all
right
do you see how do i accidentally supply
to you if I hadn't thought that properly
if I did you all what's the X cubed term
okay what's going to happen is you're
going to do 10 minus 3 in equals three
minus 3 M equals minus seven and then
you're going to be left oh this is a
binomial we have to do with whole
numbers right there is no 7 7/3 term
okay if I were to do the expansion the
very first term is going to have none of
these and fine of these you will be so
it's going to be an X to the tenth term
there will be some times about the front
as well
when I go to the next one I'll get one
of these and how many of these that what
are these money so there's gonna be four
of these right negative one that's going
to be the a the next one will be nexus7
to do you see wife with the indices
there will be an X to the negative 1 and
X to the 8th the next term over well two
of these and three of these that's uh
that's this one right so it's going to
be called X before and then they're
reading X cube and you see if what's
going to happen okay so 3x till one
subtracting one of us
all right now is just a bit side
meditative air equals to I've found the
value of any question it will give me
the correct that I want I'm just going
to put it back in turn circle equals
what I write hydrogen
I've seated for to go to and then this I
already know it's going to become X to
the 4 I need to do that again
we already this it's a teacher is that
it's going to be 160 X before this is it
okay Cambria yeah